there's another special performance
planned before the raiders take the
field tonight at allegiant stadium
the thunderbirds will fly over legion
stadium during the national anthem
they've been working on their mission
for weeks now major kyle oliver is
thunderbird six
and we spoke to him today about taking
part in his historic nights
we've been here in vegas a very long
time we love being part of the community
so to be able to be a part of this
special night in vegas
for not just the raiders but for the
whole city
to be able to represent the city of las
vegas the united states air force
it's going to be it's going to be an
incredible night so if you want to catch
the thunderbirds in person look outside
around 5
10 they're going to take off just north
of nellis air force base
head down the strip then over to the
stadium and back the thunderbirds fly
over
400 miles an hour and they should be
right over the stadium at 5
15 right in the middle of the national
anthem so